five Eco innovators as they're known are
now more than one million dollars richer
because they are winners of this year's
earthshot prize founded by William
Prince of Wales the award focuses Global
attention on startups with ideas to
address the climate crisis Prince
William awarded the prizes at a
star-studded event in Boston on Friday
and Boston was home was the hometown of
former president John F Kennedy whose
famous moonshot initiative in the 1960s
inspired the prince to create this prize
senior National and environmental
correspondent Ben Tracy was there and
looks now at the impact the prince hopes
to have
[Music]
there were high profile musical acts
right ahead please and a handful of
hand-picked celebrities what kind of
impact do you think an award like this
can have
I think it can be incredibly inspiring
Prince William's so-called Oscars for
the Earth this is the earth shot prize
2022 made the grueling work of trying to
save the planet seem glamorous at least
for a night we can overcome our planet's
greatest challenges of course when
you're handing out environmental Awards
you don't have a red carpet you have a
green one and we're told this one will
be recycled and none of the finalists
are actually here they're scattered all
over the world and they're encouraged
not to fly in to cut down on planet
warming pollution five climate and
environmental innovators were awarded
prizes worth about 1.2 million dollars
each to boost their work including a
woman in Kenya who has created cleaner
burning stoves a startup in Britain
making biodegradable plastic out of
seaweed and a group in Oman which is
taking Planet warming carbon emissions
and literally turning them to Stone
Earth shot support will enable us to
scale our solution around the world and
ultimately help us eliminate more CO2 to
help us fix our climate Christiana
figueres a Costa Rica can Diplomat
instrumental in securing the historic
2015 Paris climate Accord now chairs the
Earth shot board what can the prince and
the princess bring to this in terms of
awareness and kind of moving the ball
forward on climate action they bring an
incredible platform and an incredible
reach so the fact that he has chosen to
stand on the side of can do without a
guarantee but just to inspire everyone
all of us to live up to our absolute
best is fantastic from moonshots to
Earth shots
seemingly unsolvable can be solved
Prince William says he was inspired by
President Kennedy's moonshot in the
1960s we choose to go to the moon in
this decade and do the other things not
because they are easy but because they
are hard so it's fitting the prince
brought his prized event to the late
president's Hometown but now that the
glitz and Glam are gone the real work of
protecting the planet goes on we can
change our future for CBS mornings I'm
Ben Tracy in Boston
the world is rooting for them yeah I
hope they can use that 1.2 million
dollar